[Music]
on this monday night the prime minister
invokes the emergencies act
this is not
a peaceful protest the federal
government is ready to use
more tools at its disposal to get the
situation fully under control the new
powers the government now has to end the
protests how it vows to go after the
money and the warning to truckers
involved arrests and weapons seizures in
alberta 13 guns
handguns multiple sets of body armor
we're investigating conspiracy to
attempt to commit murder a cache of
weapons and what rcmp call the militant
mindset of some protesters
also tonight concerns deepen about what
russia is planning in ukraine ukraine's
president addresses the nation
and remembering a homegrown hollywood
hitmaker not only the world's most
authority on ghostbusters but also one
of the great storytellers of our time
the heartfelt tributes for ivan reitman
whose movies defined a generation
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
prime minister justin trudeau and his
cabinet have invoked the federal
emergencies act which gives the
government new powers to try to end the
protests that have blocked border
crossings and occupied downtown ottawa
for weeks
the emergencies act will be used to
strengthen and support law enforcement
agencies
at all levels across the country
this is about keeping canadians safe
protecting people's
jobs and restoring confidence in our
institutions
at the same time the rcmp and alberta
say they became aware of what they call
a military mindset among a small segment
of the protesters near the coots border
crossing rcmp moved in last night and
have now made 13 arrests after receiving
information about what they call a cache
of firearms with a large amount of
ammunition they released this photo of
what they say was seized long guns
handguns and high-capacity magazines
a number of different acts
has created a situation where we're
investigating conspiracy to attempt to
commit murder
it is the first seizure of weapons
during this prolonged protest and it
raises questions about whether any
weapons are present at other protests
including in ottawa where the occupation
is into its third week we'll get to all
that in just a moment but we begin with
invoking the emergencies act and what
that means our chief political
correspondent david aiken is with me
from ottawa david
well donna the first riggs parked
themselves on parliament hill 18 days
ago but it is just now today that the
federal government is declaring a
historic national emergency
but what this country is facing is a
largely foreign-funded
targeted and coordinated attack on
critical infrastructure and our
democratic institutions and so with that
the federal emergencies act has been
invoked for the first time since the
legislation was created in 1988
the police will be given more tools to
restore order in places where public
assemblies can constitute illegal and
dangerous activities the federal
government will be able to compel towing
companies for example to provide service
to local police rcmp will be given the
power to enforce municipal and
provincial laws and critical
infrastructure like border crossings
will get special protection in addition
financial institutions will be
authorized or directed to render
essential services to help address the
situation we are today serving notice
if your truck is being used in these
illegal blockades
your corporate accounts will be frozen
the insurance on your vehicle will be
suspended
notably this is not being used to call
in the military or suspend any charter
rights but it may not be the silver
bullet for the crisis a scholar who
co-wrote the textbook on the emergencies
act says the government already has all
the laws it might need they just have to
be enforced it's a matter of enforcement
not of a lack of authority or lack of
law which is usually where we would see
the need to go to a federal
emergencies act several premiers
cautioned the pm against invoking the
emergencies act they worried it will
inflame tensions and embolden protesters
secondly we have seen the prime minister
continually wedge divide and stigmatize
canadians who he doesn't agree with
and by doing so he creates so many
barriers in in terms of trying to solve
this problem ontario's doug ford was a
strong supporter of invoking the federal
emergencies act ford last week invoked
ontario's emergency powers
now given all this donna there is a
strong sense that the pm's move today is
motivated mostly by politics the desire
to be seen to be doing something
anything in a new poll out today from
the angus reid institute 72 percent said
it is time for the protesters to go home
but almost as many 68 percent said that
so far
the prime minister has only made the
situation worse donna
okay david aiken in ottawa thanks now to
alberta and the arrests of 13 people in
the seizure of long guns handguns body
armor and ammunition by the rcmp who
also allege the driver of a semi-truck
accelerated towards police swerving at
the last minute heather yorick's west is
near milk river tonight heather this is
a serious escalation take us through
what the police say they seized
well donna police say they executed a
search warrant early this morning on
three trailers in coots police say they
received information on sunday that
there was a group of protesters or
people associated with the protest i
should say who had access to weapons and
were also willing to use force against
police should police move in to disrupt
this blockade now that search revealed a
number of weapons 13 long guns were
seized as well as handguns ammunition
high capacity magazines body armor
and a machete there was also an incident
on sunday involving two vehicles
associated with the protest police say a
large tractor as well as a semi-trailer
worked together to try and ram a police
vehicle
the truth is is that there's a heavy
stash of weapons and these weapons were
brought by people who had the intent on
causing harm
heather this blockade in alberta is now
into its third week costing the economy
an estimated 44 million dollars a day
what is premier jason kennedy saying
about it
yeah the premier had stronger words
about the need to end this blockade
today he also said that his government
is assisting rcmp he says that the
government has helped to procure all of
the necessary
equipment and services needed to move
commercial vehicles from the highway
the ongoing blockade of our borders and
our highways at coots will no longer be
tolerated and now that this
very delicate security challenge has
been resolved successfully by the police
as i say broader enforcement measures
will commence
and police also say there was another
incident today involving someone
suspected to be associated with the
protest trying to run down a police
officer so a very tense situation i can
tell you that the mood has definitely
become more hostile definitely towards
the media down here but even in the last
few hours we're also seeing sort of the
the camp the crowd here in milk river
start to thin out people are deciding to
pack up and leave so perhaps some
hopeful news there but the border does
still remain blocked
still closed to traffic so this
situation is definitely far from over
donna
all right heather urex west near milk
river alberta thanks the longest and the
most entrenched protest is in the
nation's capital today some trucks did
move not away from parliament hill
though but closer to it abigail beeman
reports
the bells toll noon nothing changes here
on kent street noon ottawa mayor's
deadline to see clear evidence of trucks
moving out of residential zones after
announcing a deal with convoy organizers
nothing's changed
the mandates are still here so i'm not
going
i'm not afraid of any fines or anything
coming my way we have a point to prove
those staying put have reinforcements
this family hands out valentine's treats
this couple drove seven hours to give
out thousands in cash they need money
right they gotta eat they gotta they're
not working at one of the supply camps
outside the core complete with saunas no
movement either i'm not going anywhere
but as the afternoon wore on a number of
trucks did move some rolled off o'connor
street filling in spots in front of
parliament hill this is where we want to
be we're on parliament it took us two
weeks to get here very happy very big
day for us the motivation has been there
there since day one
but there's
people that leave and people that come
so we got to fill up the gap hold the
line protester direction is still hazy
ottawa mayor jim watson shared a letter
from organizer tamara litch
greenlighting the residential move out
but with an ever evolving multi-pronged
convoy structure conflicting messaging
abounds yes the one with tamara's name
on it it's a lie do not leave the
residential areas you are good to go
stand your ground lynch
king company take a hike you don't talk
for me mayor watson declined an
interview he's faced some criticism for
his offer to meet with protesters he
tweeted that they have begun to act on
their commitment noting it is a complex
multi-day operation this as the city
secured an injunction aimed to stop
illegal idling fires and noise but
whether and how they enforce that is
another question so too is what will
happen to this new influx of trucks
behind me parked even closer together
making any potential towing operation an
even bigger challenge abigail beeman
global news ottawa
traffic started flowing again today
across the ambassador bridge between
ontario and michigan though as mike
derle reports there's still a heavy
police presence in windsor and some
protesters are refusing to leave
this is all that's left of the protest
group that occupied the ambassador
bridge for six days a dozen or so
stragglers with one sign and a pair of
flags hanging out on a street corner a
safe distance away from police they said
as long as we stay on the sidewalk we
don't go on the road we stay peaceful as
long as we don't try to incite violence
towards them they will not try and uh
charge forward on us again
[Applause]
when it became apparent protesters
weren't going to leave on their own
police moved in early sunday morning
arresting over two dozen impounding cars
and clearing the roads leading to the
bridge
by monday traffic was light but flowing
with police controlling every
intersection between the 401 highway and
the bridge it's an expensive operation
which windsor's mayor says is essential
to prevent protesters from reoccupying
the bridge well i'll i'll never say
never i'll be obviously this has been a
very fluid and dynamic situation but i
can tell you we have strong supports on
the ground we've done everything we can
in the short term
to help control this from happening
again the economic hit in lost trade for
the province is estimated to be about
three billion dollars protesters had
demanded an immediate end to vaccine and
mass restrictions today premier doug
ford announced restrictions would start
to ease this week and while the mask
mandate will remain unchanged the
vaccine passport system will end march
1st
news that was either met with disbelief
because you guys twist it
or criticism for its promise isn't
enough if they're easing restrictions
why are you still here
because we're not waiting any longer we
need it now
but the passports will not be lifted
march 1st
march 1st yes but not now
so until they get exactly what they want
they're going to hold their ground and
they're going to keep an eye on police
and police are going to keep an eye on
them and once again the mayor drew
dilkins has said he's willing to go to
any lengths to make sure this bridge
stays open donna
mike drilling in windsor ontario tonight
thanks rising fears over russia's
intentions coming up what ukraine's
president said in an address to the
nation
public health restrictions imposed
because hospitals were overwhelmed with
people sick with covid19 are being eased
slowly across the country as
hospitalizations decline ontario's
premier announced his plans today and
made a point of saying he's not being
influenced by the anger of protesters
karen lieberman is with me from toronto
karen what's changing in ontario and
when
the province is fast-tracking plans to
remove certain restrictions on
businesses masking will still be
required but soon proof of vaccination
will be a thing of the past in ontario
we're moving in this direction
because it's safe to do so in just a few
days ontario will take a giant step
toward reopening the province removing
restrictions on most businesses having
passed the peak of the omicron wave
92 percent of ontarians 12 and over have
received at least two doses
and
6.7 million ontarians now have their
third doses so we have the level of
protection that we need to remove public
health measures capacity limits will be
removed for places like restaurants and
gyms where proof of vaccination is
required
social gathering limits will increase to
50 people indoors 100 outdoors
sporting arenas concert venues and
theaters are allowed 50
of their usual seating capacity when the
public health threat starts to abate
your policy has to align with the
current public health threat and the
best available science and that means
it's totally okay to start lifting some
of these measures perhaps the biggest
change as of march 1st you'll no longer
need to show proof of vaccination in
places like restaurants and bars gyms
concert venues and other settings
but you'll still need to wear a mask
while the premier insists fast tracking
the province's reopening schedule is
unrelated to recent anti-vaccine mandate
protests in ottawa and windsor this plan
was in place long before
the protests were out there opposition
leaders questioned his motivation if it
looks like a duck it walks like a duck
and it quacks like a duck certainly it's
a duck and i would say that's what
happened here i wouldn't be at all
surprised if doug ford himself was
largely motivated
by the fringe element that we see
occupying ottawa ford says the removal
of covid 19 public health measures has
always been the objective
many businesses will need two years to
undo the damage of the past two years
according to the canadian federation of
independent business but ontario's
chamber of commerce calls today's
announcement
positive news for business
donna karen lieberman in toronto tonight
thanks
global national is back in a moment
canada says it will provide a 500
million loan to ukraine over and above
the 120 million dollar loan previously
announced ukraine's president made
headlines today after an address to the
nation he said he'd been told a russian
attack on ukraine would begin february
16th a senior official later clarified
he was not being literal he was being
ironic
that has not calmed the situation though
because no one can predict vladimir
putin's next move
jackson proskow reports
the war drums keep beating louder as
russia continues its relentless build up
surrounding ukraine on three sides he
continues to do the things
that you would expect one to do if if
one was planning on a major military
action
monday ukraine's president defiantly
seized on the claims made by western
intelligence about an impending invasion
we are told february 16th will be the
date of attack said vladimir zelinski as
he called for solidarity we will make
that a day of national unity
sitting with vladimir putin in moscow
russia's foreign minister insisted
diplomatic options are far from
exhausted
nervous european allies still share the
view that a russian attack could come at
any moment
canada is withdrawing its military
trainers from ukraine the u.s is closing
its embassy in kiev moving the few
remaining diplomats to near the border
with poland president putin may well
decide to order an invasion and now has
the ability to do so uh in short order
in keeve local analysts remain hopeful
putin may not go all in
the access to kiev
doesn't look like to be a realistic
scenario without like a great losses
from russian side nato insists there is
still a path to peace though it's
looking narrower by the day
the best way for russia to demonstrate
its readiness to find a peaceful
solution is to de-escalate
and remove their forces which are now
threatening ukraine all the while
ukraine's future relationship with the
west hangs in the balance president
zelinski now suggests nato membership
may only be a dream for his country
a message perhaps meant to appease the
russian forces amassing at his border
jackson prosko global news washington
remembering the good slimes next
tributes to canadian director ivan
reitman i feel so funky spangler i'm
with batman
you got slime
the film world is mourning the death of
canadian director and producer ivan
reitman he created some of the most
beloved successful and funny hollywood
movies from meatballs to ghostbusters
his son jason also a director posted
today i've lost my hero all i want is
the chance to tell my father one more
story
tonight reitman is being remembered as a
great talent and an even finer man
eric sorenson reports
hey amy ghost one of the most popular
comedy films ever made ivan reitman
wrote ghostbusters in about three weeks
every molecule in your body exploding at
the speed of light right that's bad
okay it's easy for big screen comedies
to fall flat but reitman's imagination
turned offbeat ideas into hilarious
films over and over again saying he
never lost the jitters before a new
movie debuted oh absolutely i i think if
i didn't i'd have to get out he produced
some of the brightest stars on stage
before bill murray john belushi and dan
aykroyd moved to television and it was
reitman who helped launch their movie
careers
producing volusian animal house where he
made frat house antics somehow charming
and in meatballs directed bill murray's
first feature film these are the camp
rules
i'll be in here if you want to check
these out a little bit later he even
turned tough guy arnold schwarzenegger
into a comedy star feel how soft my skin
is that's it and when he made the
ghostbusters sequel he worried all over
again all through the shooting people
saying i'm really glad you're doing it
but don't ruin it we really love the
first one reitman is being remembered as
a great filmmaker and in his hometown as
a builder his family donated land for a
theater making the toronto international
film festival bigger and better he made
giant hollywood blockbusters but he
understood the value of film culture as
a whole that was important for people to
see movies from all over the world a
business partner remembers reitman as
being part of the fabric of the
community being a canadian
being
being friendly
and being genuine and that was him
reitman's parents were hungarian jews
his mother survived auschwitz his son
jason wrote today he came from a family
of survivors and turned his legacy into
laughter
jason also became a top director father
and son collaborated including on one
last installment of ghostbusters not
only the world's most you know
authority on ghostbusters but also one
of the great storytellers of our time
daughter catherine too is a comedian and
creator ivan reitman was in the world of
movies but didn't get caught up in the
fashion and glamour of it it's frankly
easier for guys you get a decent suit a
good shirt and you're done
reitman laughed easily and smiled always
it seemed fitting for a man who made so
many people laugh and smile
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is quebec city there are
beautiful spots all over this country
please email yours to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye